hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to another impossible let's
play this time featuring the hottest
sauce in the universe in dimension now
this tiny little bottle is rated in an
astonishing 3.5 million Scoville units
if you know my history with hot things
you know that I don't handle them so but
that's the point this is supposed to be
impossible so let's get to it I'm gonna
take a dollop of this I'm gonna put it
in my ice cream scoop because I didn't
have a normal spoon and then I'm gonna
play a rage game this one in particular
is called unfair sonic or Sonic unfair I
don't think it really matters because
this is gonna be ridiculous anyway so
let's do this alright okay to be honest
I'm kind of terrified because I didn't
think that I would get to this point the
idea was good and yet now it seems very
bad oh God
okay that was a lot I didn't mean to put
that much okay guys you're supposed to
only use like a drop of this and I put
pretty much an entire tablespoon onto
this thing that's the way it goes this
is how the game works this is what I'm
paid to do so let's get to it
okay okay cheers everybody
oh this is a mistake okay let's get to
the game things you get it go my god I
just said breathing in the fumes that
are left over everybody going oh my god
[Music]
am i dead okay I'm dead that's good you
holy crap he would be this bad but I
gotta do it I can do it heavy focus very
calmly oh he's good he's good it's good
burn
I like a feeling at me I can do it I can
handle the pain I've been through worse
oh how did I do it the first dad I'm
literally Quietus wedding my body oh
good gravy
foggy help help me shut up everybody
[Music]
particularly I can't boys anymore
I think I'm ready they got that up I'm
going in this house
[Music]
oh my god hey hey that was intense
I'm sorry my face is a bit of a mess I
apologize oh my goodness who those let
me let me describe the experience the
instant it hit my lips it might hit
anything in here it burnt my flesh to
the bone it incinerated everything away
from my insides and then just blew it up
in flames it was incredible that was
probably the most intense burn I've ever
had of anything and this milk gallon was
up to here before I didn't realize I was
doing the milk challenge as well but
that was that was oddly fun oddly enough
I'm probably just getting that endorphin
rush I've heard that after you have a
very hot thing you get a rush of
endorphins after the pain subsides and
it's like because right now I'm like a
little too giddy for just what I went
through
oh my god I was getting glances of my
webcam here and I just saw it like spit
and saliva and tears going everywhere I
apologize for how disgusting that was
but just for the sake of me going
through that please if you enjoyed this
leave a like down below please let me go
through all that for nothing and if you
have an idea for what you want me to do
in the next impossible let's play
hopefully not a hot thing again but it's
not you know I could do it I've got a
hotter sauce over here and I didn't do
that one that one I don't even want to
touch but that was surprisingly fun so
thank you guys so much for watching
and as always I will see you in the next
video bye-bye
[Music]